lutz meinen steifen schwanz abgepackter
[ __ ] iges etwas ok alles klar ich
hatte mein namens luke und herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
und zwar immer wieder so meinen
kommentaren unterwegs und hab mir so ein
paar kommentare rausgesucht die so ein
bisschen na ja ich würde nicht sagen
dumm sind aber schon dumm sind
leck mich am arsch noch verdammt
ok messi magnus aber das krasse ist ja
danach schreibt er nämlich noch einen
kommentar entschuldigung
er schreibt mir wirklich erst einen
kommentar in dem er sagt leck mich am
arsch loch verdammt und danach schreit
er mir entschuldigung kannst du dich mal
bitte entscheiden last man lukas schwanz
größe herausfinden ein zentimeter gleich
ein like und ich zeige euch mal wie
viele likes auf diesen kommentar gab
parkscheine sluka ich habe null
zentimeter schwanz nicht schlimm luca
dass sich viele hassen dann leiche ich
immer das ist sehr cool user mit dem
namen lp mit gehrmann dein ohr
also er sagt wirklich hier mit luca egal
dass nicht viele hassen dafür leid ich
doch immer dann ist es natürlich direkt
wettgemacht leute wenn ihr der gleichen
meinung seid die lp mit der man geilo
dann leicht allemal dieses video viele
hassen mich aber wenn ihr leicht an
ihr seid so gestört das gefällt mir
dieser kommentar hat einfach 889 lies
leute fast 1000 leute denken dass max
und ich übelst gestört sind dieser
kommentar an dem ich unter dem video
home max und ich die youtuber kabul
köpfen gemacht haben
da hab ich das video hat nochmal hier
oben irgendwo verlinkt ich bin sehr
stolz auf dieses video ich fand es ist
sehr sehr cool gewesen
es ist ja auch euch megafon angekommen
von den klicks leider nicht so viel aber
derzeit ist die ganzen trends und
youtube sind auch voll mit irgendwelchen
america video aber wir machen wir weiter
mit dem nächsten lyrisch natürlich auch
wieder hammer mäßigen kommentare und
zwar habe ich in einem video gesagt wo
ich eine challenge mit max gemacht habe
dass alle leute die das noch mal ziehen
wollen das machst du nicht nur tennis
gegeneinander machen einfach mal das
wort challenge in die kommentare
schreiben sollen also challenge09
geschrieben challenge lieber jojo 44
wenn du deutsch nachhilfe benötigt melde
dich einfach bei mir schreibt wir die
nachricht bei instagram hier ist der
laser luca schreibt mir einfach mal dann
kann ich dir vielleicht weiterhelfen
es gibt ja derzeit auf youtube sehr
viele kommentare die so in die richtung
gehen wie beschäftigt man einen idioten
und dann mehr anzeigen aber darunter
schreiben weil wenn man bei youtube da
geht es ja dieses mehr anzeigen und ich
glaube ihr wissen
dass ich meine in der tat auf jeden fall
wollen sie das dann eine auf meiner
familie hier auch immer ganz cool machen
und hat dann das hier geschrieben wie
beschäftigt man einen idioten hier die
links warum schreibst du hier viel links
warum hast du überhaupt liegt das habe
ich schon oft videos hochgeladen wo ich
einfach böse kommentare vorgelesen habe
und da gab es doch oft so kommentare
wurden beispielsweise einige sehr
gestiegen da kommen wir erzählen eine
geschichte es war einmal ein luca und
dann kamen teilweise so 1000 kommentare
wo die leute geschrieben habe was ich
dann so mache dann hab ich diese leute
fast selbst oder eigene geschichte
zusammen geschrieben und da hat ein user
jetzt das ganze wieder vor allem tag und
haben im video probiert allerdings hat
nicht so gut geklappt und zwar hat er
halt geschrieben wir erzählen eine
geschichte jeder nur einen satz conny
gibt in den wald punkt um punkt und das
war's ja keine antworten bekommen und
die geschichte ist quasi mit dem satz
beendet conny gibt in den wald die
schaffer von hänsel und gretel und allen
anderen hammer geschichten weil alle
sind neidisch auf dich vielleicht
schaffen wir in diesem video die längste
geschichte in den youtube kommentaren
allen zeiten zu erschaffen war das
überhaupt richtiges deutsch wenn ihr
dieses video gerade seht ihr
wahrscheinlich schon unten einen
kommentar von mir angeboten das heißt es
da oben angezeigt wird in den ich
geschrieben habe kommen wir erzählen
eine geschichte es war einmal ein luca
punkt um punkt und ihr müsst dann auf
diese kommentare antwort ich weiß nicht
ob wir schaffen können aber irgendwie so
10.000 kommentare einfach
unser meinem kommentar dass wir so eine
eigene geschichte machen dann mache ich
ein video wo ich das alles vorlese also
guckt in die kommentare
antwortet auf meinen kommentar und dann
schreiben wir zusammen geschichte
wir nehmen pdps abonnenten und schieben
sie bei lukas rein okay der user mit dem
namen in sky gesagt dass wir einfach die
abonnenten von p die pdp ich glaube er
oder sie meinen beauty teilnehmen die
abonnenten von juniper und schieben sie
in meiner abonnenten rein
ich bin ich weiß nicht ob du arzt bist
und ich glaube dass es nicht so
hygienisch warum beleidigt man dich du
bist ein richtig heißer youtuber alles
klar egal ich bin eine haider youtuber
auf jeden fall danke an die user mit dem
namen chaos schatten 44 ab und ich weiß
dann deine aussage jetzt dass ich nicht
kaputt bin ich bin ein heiler youtube
duca lass dich nicht ärgern hast linke
okay
warum lasse ich mich überhaupt erkannt
ich hab doch linke ist eine linke hand
ich habe im linken fuß hier was ich
sagen wir mal einen fuß hier haben
linken fuß linke hand ich habe linkes
ohr linkes auge warum das ich mich
endlich erkannt ich leide mit dir luca
bleibe stark nimmt das leben nicht so
schwer luft liebe ein gummibär ok walter
okay dass mein leben bald ihr euch
übrigens fragt wieso die
kameraperspektive hier wieder so ein
bisschen anders ist das liegt ganz
einfach wieder daran dass naja couchepin
an professional youtube daumen hoch hat
trotzdem herbst war wie kommt man auf
solche kommentare daumen hoch hab
trotzdem
dass das ist das ist ja das macht über
das ist als wenn du bist ein programm
mit haben wir jetzt wirklich ein
komplett neues level an beleidigungen
erreicht also ich dachte wirklich jetzt
kommen dann so böse kommentare wenn ich
mir danach suchen so dass ich über so
[ __ ] denn die größte missgeburt
oder wikis spiel sagen würde drohte ich
weiß zwar nicht wann es cool ist eine
sexuelle orientierung als beleidigung zu
nutzen aber marcel gut gebracht aber
dieser kommentar du bist ein tor das ist
echt das ist spitzenklasse der
beleidigung freunde das ist hammer sowas
will ich sehen in den kommentaren sie
dir mal deine videos du bist aber echt
dumm lieber user mit dem namen lukas
perman sie dir mal deine videos du bist
aber echt dumm du beherrschst keine
grammatik keine große kleinschreibung du
bist wer steine punktierung und du
kannst dir nicht mehr auf deinen eigenen
kommentar antworten sondern muss zwei
einzelne meine freundinnen ist bei mir
meine freude ist bei mir was willst du
hast du schon einmal was von
rechtschreibung gehört ja herzlich
willkommen weil ich dort ihre bestellung
bitte dich heißt sich mit donezk um
einen steifen schwanz abgepackter uhren
sonniges etwas ok alles klar ja ich
glaube das solltest du tatsächlich
lieber bei katja glaser witz in die
kommentare schreiben
bei mir bist du gern gesehen wenn du
irgendwas mit pizza schreibst sorry luca
du siehst manchmal richtig scheiße aus
alles klar
also ich finde es wirklich aber was für
eine positive energie in den kommentaren
ist dass dies wirklich immer wenn ich
schlecht gelaunt bin und ich ihnen die
motivation brauche schaue ich mir die
kommentare kein dhea wo du bist der
beste
normale leute schreiben hey du bist
richtig cool du bist der westlich las
man aber da er schreibt einfach er lässt
kein abo da leute wenn ihr cool seid
dann lasst mal alle kein dhea robert
panel da ich bin ich kann ich kann ich
gc
ich lerne deutsch xd klappt es ja
richtig coole auf jeden fall luca du
alter lappen ich meine wir nicht
wenigstens neuer lampen gewesen wäre
aber laut die bin ich ein alter lampen
deswegen sollten wir eine ganz kurze
sache ich also ich möchte es nicht dass
ihr wieder so ganz viele kommentare
schreiben von wegen ey lässt sich davon
nicht unterkriegen du bist doch so super
also könnt ihr natürlich trotzdem
schreiben ich freue mich darüber aber
ihr müsst wirklich wissen dass ich du
gerade wirklich eine stunde gebraucht
habe um diese ganzen kommentare
rauszusuchen also ich find's einfach mal
ein großes danke an euch dass ihr so
eine barmherzige liebe community seit
und dass ich so lange brauche um das
alles zu finden weil bei manchen youtube
dann muss man nur in die kommentare
schauen und findet direkt 400.000 stück
die halt irgendwie gegen den youtuber
gerichtet sind also ich bin euch
wirklich sehr dankbar dass ihr ja dass
ihr quasi mitleid mit mir hat weil ich
so ein dummer mensch bin ich bin nach
afghanistan geflogen und du warst nicht
darüber warum sollte ich in afghanistan
sein wo fließt nach afghanistan um mich
zu sehen warum habe ich ihnen mein
videos gesagt dass ich in afghanistan
bin ein paar sekunden später
ich glaub nicht zeitgleich stillen 80
bin dir unendlich dankbar
userin mit dem namen miri 1000 super ich
finde es super dass du mir das
beigebracht hast also ich hätte ich mir
nie darauf gekommen dass silent night
stille nacht auf deutsch übersetzt heißt
das ist wirklich dass es das bereichert
meine weltanschauung ein komplettes bild
von der menschheit komplett wird findet
das comfort otto lukat lieber andré
goncalves
das ist zwar kein schlechter kommentar
und es ist auch kein böser kommentar und
auch kein dummer kommentar ich habe ihn
aber hier mal mit reingenommen weil naja
ich hab nichts gegen dich aber
beschreibt diesen kommentar unter jedes
meiner videos und bekommen so vor als
wenn du einfach bei jedem youtuber der
irgendwie videos hochlädt aktiv
benachrichtigungen an gemacht hat und
immer wenn er eins hochlädt schreibt so
direkt über diesen kommentare das
konkreter luca der beste oder halt bei
anderen youtube findet das green day
wird die beste ist findet dass sie die
beste ist wenn findet darfst du julien
der beste ist ich habe das gefühl ist
dass bei jedem macht das schon bei sehr
vielen leuten von mir gesehen habe und
das heißt für mich einfach dass das
sonne so eine serbe taktik ist dass
leute dann das licon du wirst höher
angezeigt die leute geht doch kein kanal
das ist nicht so cool
verstehst was ich meine oder versteht
ihr was ich meine
definitiv nein leute jetzt als letzter
kommentar 1 kommentar der sehr sehr
lyrisch wirklich auf einem sehr sehr
hohen niveau ist haha opfer also dieser
kommentar beschreibt diese folge
komplett das was ihr vom video meine
damen und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen weil es getan hat lassen
das schaffen wir 50.000 live schaffen
wir ähnlich oder am definitiv büchern zu
beginn gesagt
ihr findet in den kommentaren einen
kommentar von mir angepinnt dass wir
eine geschichte schreiben sollen also
schreibt einen kommentar schreibt eine
antwort kommentar auf diesen kommentar
und wir versuchen die längste größte
youtube kommentar geschichte aller
zeiten zu machen
hier findet hier ein smiley eigen nennen
wir darauf wie könnt ihr meinen kanal
abonnieren dadurch verpasste keine
videos mehr das ist kostenlos und darum
findet ihr auch mal shop eingeblendet wo
es seit heute diese top sockets gibt
also diese teile mit dem man sein handy
festhalten kann in schwarz und hier
findet irgendein anderes video
eingeblendet